yeah welcome to a new let's video and
I'm playing Knight f3 against on a Dutch
international master it's um the
national master one I go okay so we've
got c5 arm let's transpose to the
civilian and for whatever reason I'm 50
seconds down where on earth did i lose
so much time okay we've got done since
his c3 sassanian type of position and
transpose into an endgame and don't mind
to have a simple position really wet it
I am what did I lose this time I of
course I had a look um at the profile
wanted to know where who this is still
um I'm amazed that this took so long yep
okay I want to get some space on the
queenside end also get an ID to see
three so Bishop e3 em yeah let's let's
put the bishop here looks like a good
square b6 assault so on maybe I'm a
useful post for this Bishop controlling
the the D file so let's um let's do this
if he exchanges okay Rupert e7e oh ok so
he avoided that but this also means some
I'm not quite sure how he how he
continues
let's let's approve the position of it
with the normal move huh okay let's wrap
here first so that the night has to
retreat and then or maybe take andrew q1
yeah this is probably better so we
exchanged on some some pieces yeah I
don't mind getting a good night on e5 so
um question is some how to proceed yet
looks like i should have a bit a bit of
an advantage I think that some gain gain
some space after g5 why does he go
centralizing now let's just drop more
space and the King has a natural way to
to advance him
or to f3 this should be a good square
with 95 as a possibility the I shouldn't
be too bad so if i do nighty for now how
is this end game at threatened to take
so he probably needs to take with the
bishop and I should be better in this
end game with the bishop against the
night
yeah it's got the problems the
opponent's eyes weekend I've got this
beep on let's not turn not so easy I
think to defend not so firm moves are a
really problematic now yeah this um I
thought should be still quite okay
nevertheless Knight to c8 oh this is
maybe one idea if I go b6 now here just
dumb ooh yeah how does he continue after
be 69 c 8 is not working how come on I
think I need to do that forgot about
this move this probably is secure some
secures the draw I don't have I don't
have enough enough pawns left
wait just just a second it takes b7 this
is a promotion and no the night yeah
it's it's in a drop it's still a drum
cannot turn cannot do much yeah I
thought maybe there is something to try
but there is there really isn't yeah it
certainly was so what's better at some
point I'd really like to know maybe of
course I this the the the the night g6
move so is something that I didn't I
didn't take into account maybe I need to
play Bishop to have seven or something
first of course I exchanged be against
the poem but I need to get get to the
pawns or Bishop d3 and white wins okay
yeah it's clear that white is close to
winning I mean Bishop f7 not here Jack
computer sync this is equal yeah maybe I
don't he's got 95 okay
so Bishop to d3 yeah okay no not g6 I
have h 5 and this is this rather clear
that why just winning us the King Justin
weights and of course the bishop is just
the better piece there he was he was
really a really worse him after you five
especially it's simply a weakness I mean
why play e5 you could also keep the
position more on more compact yeah
interesting endgame thanks for watching